who wins
in a fight to the death
or maybe a uh in a sport competition
setting but let's go with a fight to the
death uh a grizzly bear
a Silverback Gorilla
and maybe a lion or tiger an African
lion or uh one of the flavors of tiger
I don't know who you think is more
ferocious what are the parameters to
consider here maybe I can throw a few
out and maybe you can give me
some thoughts about how much of these
parameters matter so first of all
intelligence
I do believe the gorilla is the most
intelligent I've did research for this
as you can imagine
[Laughter]
with Joe Rogan uh the the expert advisor
to this very podcast on this very topic
is indeed Joe Rogan yes uh so in
captivity guerrillas have been
documented to show complex emotions from
family bonds the ability to use tools
and to be able to reason about the past
and the future that's impressive so that
that's something that at least in
captivity the other animals have not
been able to do they already sound much
more advanced than I am
um
yeah so
that's intelligence then there is weight
I think that's something that you think
of at first uh the lion let's go with
the big ones that I took notes Here 550
pounds for big lion that's exceptionally
large like most male lines are around
450 pounds that's an exceptional Beast
then
thank you
um the the tiger can be larger than that
yeah much much larger
so we got the grizzly bear which is
probably the biggest of the bunch at uh
the large ones get to uh 1500 pounds
correct me some of this numbers I
believe most Grizzlies around a thousand
pounds big big beast I was looking up
the biggest but I didn't want to do the
biggest ever
I just wanted the big like the top of
the range because there's always the
range you can put it in a roughly double
that of even a very big lion
of course how that weight is used is
very important uh so there's also things
which I find is interesting as Anaconda
would just let me throw that in there
because there is 200 pounds what I
really like about that is it's not just
the way it's the form factor and I think
out of all of these the ancana is the
most
non-standard form factor which I totally
agree with that yeah it's like the the
uh the Knight on the chessboard it comes
in from a completely different angle so
we got that we got also uh
a strength in which could be measured in
ability to carry stuff so this was
surprising to me I did look into this
carefully the grizzly bear at a thousand
or 1500 pounds can only carry at most
its body weight which is a lot
but a gorilla can carry 10 times his
body weight a gorilla can lift over 2
000 kilograms that's over four thousand
pounds and gorillas themselves and adult
male weighs in around 350 to 400 400
pounds yes that's so I like how in this
particular place where I found this to 2
000 kilograms is as heavy as 30 average
humans so gorillas
30 humans so that's carrying string and
then of course uh bite force because
that's one of the weapons in question
here so agree now this is really
surprising to me I the gorilla has won
me over through this by the way uh
intelligence I'm gonna sucker for
intelligence but the gorilla bite force
is the highest of all these with 1300
PSI bear a second with 1200 PSI tiger is
uh a third I think tiger and lions
they're with a thousand PSI that's
comparable and a bear is uh anywhere
from 900 to 1000 PSI they're close but
gorilla I would not have expected now
that's gorilla is not a carnivore but
apparently you choose it's mostly it's
grassy stuff right but it like
it's difficult to explain why it has
such a powerful bite and it also of
course has very large in size of teeth
as well as chewing teeth so um also no
neck yeah
so because Nick begins at the top of his
head and this goes down to the shoulders
well a lot of the way they use their
teeth
all of these animals they the the
ultimate kill is to go for the neck the
bite in the neck I don't know exactly
why that is probably
has to do
why is that because it's a very strong
controlled position not just that it's a
is it the same as Jiu-Jitsu you think
because they get to also choke them out
it's very much in line with you just
like lions are famous for using
strangulation as their primary method of
killing they they get a hold of the neck
and hold until
um the animal drops plus uh claws
I believe the tiger and the bear use
their claws and the lion too the lion
right and the lion uh
this is something that the gorilla
doesn't do
and uh Anaconda obviously doesn't yeah
so what what do you think how do we
think about this also there is uh I'm
just not letting you talk apparently
there's uh levels of aggression in terms
of these are also very important
considerations yeah what what is um all
the considerations you've raised are
very important and we we would have to
address them if we're going to go
through this topic
um first things first
whenever you go into a discussion of
this kind there's
a kind of natural impression that we all
have as to which one would be the most
formidable
um
and
it's important that you become rather
skeptical of your first intuitions
because they're often very misleading
just as every boy thinks his father is
the strongest man in the world
and then when he grows up into adulthood
he realizes
this father was not even close to being
the strongest man in the world it's not
because
of anything other than an experience to
a boy his father seemed overwhelmingly
strong he literally can't even imagine
if anyone else being stronger than that
so
naively he thinks his father is the
strongest man in the world so too in our
relationship with animals
when we look at a Silverback Gorilla it
just looks overwhelmingly strong to us
to a degree which is almost absurd like
um
you picture the greatest combat athletes
that Humanity has ever produced the
prime Mike Tyson Gordon Ryan for
grappling
they would literally be torn limb from
limb by an angry gorilla it wouldn't
even be remotely competitive and so
there's a sense in which we look at them
in awe because of what they could do to
us
but that can be very misleading and just
as a boy
looks at his father as like the Pinnacle
of strength you can't necessarily from a
position of inexperience and weakness
look at a given animal and say oh that
must be the toughest animal in the
animal kingdom there's levels to this
game and
um I think we can point out that the
gorilla ultimately would be pretty low
on those levels
push back to this analysis because the
data we don't have much data on this we
don't have we actually have slightly
more than you think I believe oh boy
well it's anecdotal I feel like it's out
of context so these species don't use
this is not MMA they don't do
inter-species fighting often
yeah but there are some ways of looking
at this which can take this already
interesting question and make it a lot
more interesting
um
first we've seen that intuitions aren't
to be trusted so if intuitions aren't to
be trusted or what is to be trusted here
well I've always believed that there are
three
General
elements that determine
what level of success or failure anyone
will experience in combat and this is
true both for individuals and for groups
and even all the way out to Nations
um
the first is what are your skills the
second is what are your physical and
mental attributes so it's skills
attributes those are the two primary
ones and there's a third
which is your experience in using those
skills and attributes and real world
scenarios okay so whenever two we'll
start with two humans when two humans
get into a fight ask yourself what is
their skill set
what are their physical and mental
attributes and what is their experience
and using those in real world
applications and that will give you your
first
look at uh okay who's going to be the
more successful
um
then in addition to those
three General elements there's also four
more specific elements
what is the ability
of the combatants to initiate combat
because initiation is a big deal in
fighting the one who sees the enemy
first and can create Ambush conditions
or
initiate compact combat in an area or a
Terrain which is favorable to them this
is huge in determining the uh the
outcome of battles
second
not only is initiation important but
disengagement is important a lot of
battles don't go according to plan and
so your ability to disengage at will and
break off and away from a battle is key
to success so initiation and
disengagement are big
the third big element
what is your ability to end a fight
okay do you have an efficient method of
ending conflict
without that
the conflict could go on to a point
where you no longer have the ability to
uh to continue it if you have some
succinct method of finishing this is
huge in combat and determining winner or
loser so both from a winning and a
losing position yeah so if you don't
have one there's a much higher chance
you'll lose but if you have an ability
to finish an opponent in the conflict uh
reliably this is
very very important in determining
success or failure
and third is your ability to endure a
conflict longer than the person you're
engaged in okay so engage with sorry and
so you get these four more specific
elements now do you have the ability to
initiate contact at will do you have the
ability to break contact and disengage
at will
do you have the ability to finish your
opponent efficiently and do you have the
ability to endure longer than your
opponent does if you have all four of
those
that's huge for for combat that probably
applies to human on human everything
military conflict everything even all
the way up to Nations
um
also ask yourself
what are the most efficient
methods of combat
across the globe across all species all
times
etc etc and you'll see that ultimately
they always come down to
three things
the first is concentration of force
okay one of the most successful
combat strategies of all time is the
ability to take
concentrated Force against a zone of
weakness in your opponent and if you can
do this
you will often break through to a point
of vulnerability attack that
vulnerability in a way where your
opponent cannot respond and cannot
recover from that vulnerable point being
broken do a high amount of damage with
Precision yes so this is one of the
great combat strategies in across the
animal kingdom across human history Etc
the second would be Ambush tactics
if you can Ambush an opponent with the
element of surprise this is huge for
success in combat they're almost all of
the truly successful Predators on this
planet are Ambush Predators
the ability to get off to a good start
in a way where opponents simply can't
recover is huge for combat are we
allowing ambush in our discussion
because humans would call this cheating
perhaps yes we would and
humans are pretty damn good at it too so
um uh and then the third is endurance
okay some uh
[Music]
species some people uh humans actually
are pretty good at this
um use endurance as a weapon and they
simply wear an opponent down over time
and break them and internationally this
can be done economically
um through numbers etc etc and uh and
you can destroy someone with just sheer
endurance yeah a lot of words throughout
human history has been Siege Warfare
yeah and so when you ask yourself okay
which one of these animals are going to
uh be the most successful in combat ask
yourself well there's these three
Elements which tend to determine
Successful Failure and warfare
um which animals exhibit these three
principles the best and we'll discuss
this but as far as um
uh generalities go uh whenever you ask a
question who will win between a and b
ask yourself
in terms of the light of what we've just
discussed
what is their skill set
what are the attributes both mental and
physical what is their experience in
utilizing these in real world situations
and then the four uh more technical
elements who gets to initiate contact
can you break off contact at any given
time uh what is your endurance can you
keep going uh longer than your opponent
does so a skill set I wonder if a big
component of that of how much practice
there is off off the battle exactly so
how much quote unquote you would
probably call it play
like play fighting let's start going
through our animals okay when you look
at the gorilla
you will see immediately that almost
every experience a gorilla has of combat
is theatrical
yes they don't engage in killing things
they scare rival males away in order to
gain ownership of females but there is
almost no
uh intra species death and those
conflicts they're almost entirely
theatrical they have for example
enormous
canine teeth but there is no record of
them ever being used in combat
um
they appear to be used purely for
intimidation purposes
there's a sense in which they have this
tremendous appearance and they have
tremendous potential they they really do
have freakish levels of strength
in in many different ways
and yet the actual track record of using
it is negligible it's so strange that
Evolution will develop such as a sewing
machine like they're bite force just
makes no sense with regard to what they
actually eat I think well no I I think
that even the presence of canines
doesn't make a lot of sense they're not
going to use them what are they it comes
down to this idea their big thing is
intimidation so as a show you wanna
uh fake it and don't care if you ever
make it because fake is good enough
given that particular Dynamic now let's
contrast that with
a male lion
's
take on the biggest meanest
toughest animals in the most competitive
killing War
on planet Earth which is Continental
Africa
um and they
literally just take I mean occasionally
they lose but
it's rare and they take out everything
just in order to eat they have to take
down wildebeest cape buffalo they they
keep Buffalo are incredibly dangerous
beasts just by themselves and yet Lions
regularly take them down
um occasionally large numbers of lions
will even swarm elephant and over 12
hour periods take down elephant on some
occasions this is all on videos it's not
just speculation so they just have a
level of combat experience which no
other animal
if I were to also project so the the
Eastern European style of wrestling
where they spend so many hours on the
map they really value the number of
hours on the mat at play from childhood
the Lions probably for my extensive
watching videos on YouTube they seem to
play with each other yeah for fun a lot
and I guess even really helps you see it
you don't interact you don't play with
other gorillas you have
like you're more spending a lot more
time around
uh the opposite sex yeah so yeah I mean
even Lions uh when they they fight each
other the mortality rate when lions
fight each other male lions for
ownership of a pride
is very very high much much higher than
I believe any other species on Earth
um they're almost always fights to the
depth for the simple reason that when a
male lion loses control of a pride the
First Act the new lion does is to kill
the genetic offspring of the previous
male lion so when a lion fights another
male lion when one male lion fights
another it's not just a fight for his
own life it's a fight for his genetic
offspring and failure means not only
does he die
all his offspring dies and so when they
fight the implications are so deep it's
it's like a fight for your not just you
but your your DNA
um
most male lions have very short runs at
the top to get
killed or run off by by other Lions
um
now
this kind of harsh combat experience no
other animal can claim to have this
between what they kill to eat and what
they have to do to defend their their
stake and a pride
no other animal fights like that
um
they just bring a level of depth to
combat which is unmatched in the animal
kingdom they also have some other
elements too that they get to they get
the luxury because of their social
nature of taking more risks than other
animals like a tiger hunts alone so if
it gets injured it's a big problem it
can die if it's injured a lion can fight
uh cape buffalo get injured and be
covered by the other lions for food
until it recovers so it learns to take
risks and it's not afraid to go out and
fight very very hard whereas other
animals tend to shy away from risk
because they're solitary bears are
solitary that tigers are solitary so
they learned from an early age not to
take the big risks to go to a certain
level and stop if I could push back so
that's that's aggression and risk-taking
that's a plus for the lion but to defend
the gorilla because he says skill set
they are of all of those the only ones
that use tools I've shown to use tools
we didn't say anything about weapons a
gorilla could in theory pick up a rock
and it does have the like the force the
power and the capabilities to do a lot
of damage so it doesn't have the
practice it doesn't have the experience
but don't you think
if if a gorilla's back is to the wall so
you put them in a situation of it is
life and death
for both The Lion and the gorilla don't
you don't you value intelligence at
least a little bit here
um there's a reason why humans this is
like evidence that you know humans have
spread all across the world while being
kind of weak
why okay intelligence is a huge huge
asset humanity is positive proof that it
is the most important asset but it takes
time in order to
work is Magic it took humans
200 000 years to go from the bottom of
the food chain to the top of the food
chain
um and gorillas have a lot of work to do
before they get to that level uh you
said you said in theory gorillas could
do this but let's talk about practice
now first off there are many documented
incidents of leopards killing gorillas
that's that's anecdotal evidence no it's
not there's a bunch of bitch-ass
gorillas walking around we know this
we're asking not anecdotal it was
observed by a group of people who
specialized in in observing gorillas
over a 12-year period a regularly found
gorilla toes in lipidification
um they also saw that over a certain
period some 36 gorillas have been killed
and evidence strongly suggested leopard
predation was the reason apparently the
leopards had figured out that there is a
femoral artery
and gorilla's legs and we're doing a
move which from the sounds of it sounds
a lot like a baron bolo where they were
spinning underneath gorillas and biting
the femoral artery and then disengaging
and watching them bleed out and die and
then eating them now a leopard
is no match for a lion it the only
defense it has to align is to run up a
tree it cannot engage with a lion on
anything close to equal terms it may
seem like we're going out of tangents
but we're not just because of the foot
the attack of the artery and the foot
is there weaknesses that the lion might
have of that what I'm saying is I I know
it's not equivalent but the the fact
that a leopard does so well against even
fully grown male gorillas
makes you should make you rather
suspicious of a gorilla's ability to
fight a lion
fair enough let's also go further into
let's talk about concentration of force
the lion has the quintessential
concentration of force which is fangs
and claws
the gorilla is the exact opposite it
can't even make a fist
and so it can only throw open-handed
slaps and grab things so it it has no
ability with its with its arms to
concentrate force in any kind of
efficient way when a lion or a tiger
story or a bear for that matter swings
at you it's got four Claws from four to
six inches long it's like four blades
going into you they can retract their
claws so they're always sharp but the
reach is significantly longer for the
gorilla
the length of the the ability to engage
with speed on the part of the the cat is
is far far greater and also mobility and
to feed the bipedal nature of a gorilla
the the the temporary Barbados this is
the bear has the same no impact humans
are bipedal and lions kill 240 humans a
year on average
so okay okay okay what about bear now
beer is a difference for all the same
things that a lion has
the claws the teeth has more weight it
has more strength has more power
okay now this is an interesting question
okay you get a fully grown North
American Grizzly versus an African lion
this is an interesting fact I also have
questions about polar bears it's unclear
to me because they're big they're bigger
in every way than than a Grizzly yes but
they probably don't get the experience
in the practice yeah also they have a
much more limited set of uh animals that
they they Prey Upon so pretty sure
Grizzly is going to be tough to beat as
far as Top beer goes
um
um a grizzly bear
I believe would be a formidable
adversary even for a for a male lion
um that literally twice their size
they have an ability to get away from
strangleholds by standing up on two legs
so the Lion's primary method of killing
which is this strangle would be very
difficult for them to employ upon a bear
um
interestingly the Bear's primary method
of killing is to pin it pins animals and
then just slowly eats them while they're
still alive they have a rather barbaric
means of killing lions are much more
Humane in the way they kill
um
I what I see is the primary problem is
that neither one would ever be able to
kill the other uh that finishing thing
yeah they both fail on the finishing
criteria
the lion would not be able to strangle a
bear even in the best case scenario
where he got his teeth into the neck the
bear can stand up and and presumably
Shake him off
um uh the uh the the the the bear would
never be able to pin a lion for long
enough to better hold it down and and
slowly Maul it over time the way it can
with an elk or a caribou so I don't
believe either would be able to finish
the other it would just become exhausted
it would be it would come down to
endurance now that's where things get
interesting because the bear is much
more of an endurance Hunter and the line
is much more of an ambush Hunter lines
quick explosive much higher top speed
they've got a top speed of 45 to 50
miles an hour a beer can do up to 35 but
it can run for long periods at up to 25
miles an hour very long periods they're
mostly a uh an endurance Hunter they
just run
uh elk and moose down until they're
exhausted and then pin them and kill
them
so if it came down to endurance
might go the way of the beer if there
were if they were caged up together
however there is very strong evidence
from both hunters and video
which shows on many occasions beer is
being chased off by
cougar
and Wolverines
now what's that that's fear what is that
what do you mean chased off uh if they
fight over uh uh meat which uh and say
for example the cougar has killed
something and the bear wants to meet the
cougar will come there risk aversion
exactly exactly the Bears are
risk-averse what I would say is this the
beers are very very powerful in their
domain but they don't have the battle
experience of a lion they don't take on
animals as tough as a cape buffalo they
don't take on elephant what the toughest
thing it would probably take on probably
a a bull moose and uh a bull moose is a
formidable animal but it's nothing like
a cape buffalo it's nothing like an
elephant an elephant or a hippopotamus
so what I would suggest is this
in the wild I don't believe either one
is capable of killing the other but I do
believe based on video evidence of
cougars and Wolverines chasing off bears
that a lion would provide
enough threat
in a brief fight that a bear would back
away if you put them in a cage however
where neither one could back away I
would slightly favor the bear
based on the fact that it neither one
can kill each other would come down to
endurance you mean like an octagon yeah
that's got to be the next UFC by the way
beer versus
things change Joe Rogan's a big fan of
the idea of fighting in a stadium for
humans fighting in a stadium
um so in the stadium of bear I would I
would slightly favor a beer now I still
think that the lion would have a chance
but I would favor the Bear in a berry
match
um some of the best evidence we have for
animal versus animal fights come from
the ancient Romans who actually used to
put animals in gladiatorial combat and
um
they for example had several incidents
where they wrote about tiger vs lion
uh conflict and uh in one famous passage
they described a lion getting destroyed
by a a female tiger
um so there's there's some evidence to
suggest that they had more expertise of
this than we do because they they had a
big population of wild animals which
they just put to fight each other
um unfortunately there's nothing that
they wrote about beers versus lion they
did talk about uh bears versus bulls uh
they did talk about Lions versus Tigers
um but they never mentioned bear vs lion
so we don't have any evidence for that
so we have to be a little bit more
speculative now given that bears do get
chased off by cougar and cougar is weak
compared with a male lion they'll listen
to you draw from that by the way I would
suggest that is it about the Bears yeah
it's more about the bear like in theory
a beer should be able to crush a cougar
but it seems to be the beer is a scene
uh this thing could hurt me so I'm not
gonna risk injury and backs away I think
it would back away in the wild from a
lion but put him in a cage and I
slightly favor them the grizzly based on
endurance
so the final conclusion
if you had to just bet everything you
owned so you got uh let's say we got the
Octagon we bring in a bear
now this is like legendary bear okay
full grown Grizzly full grown Grizzly
but not only that that Grizzly is seeing
some [ __ ] what's the most it could have
seen a bull moose
a caribou that's the toughest opponent
has ever had it once no no no no no this
one once ran into a pack of other
Grizzlies and had to fend and he's got a
scarf Grizzlies there's no pack of
Grizzlies they're solitary wolves wolves
wolves what was a good practice for a
bear who attacks a bear that's that's my
point Bears don't really live in a
competitive environment lines but
sometimes it can get desperate as it was
a pack of wolves but that pack of wolves
is nothing that that's nothing all right
fine Lions deal with packs of hyenas
okay what was the just imagine over the
past hundred years what do you think is
the hardest fight
that a grizzly bear has been in like
somewhere in Alaska we never heard all
of a sudden in the middle of the night
all you hear is the bear just they
didn't really there's there's nothing
that does God have been something humans
have killed
cougars and Wolverines like no that's
anecdotal evidence there's got to be one
bear there's video footage of it you can
watch it yes it's called anecdotal
evidence there's got I guarantee you in
the dark of the night there was an epic
battle of which there's still Legend
amongst the Bears in that part of Canada
who did it battle in Canada moose are
the Bears you don't think they'd go at
it yeah bears fight each other but it's
largely theatrical they never kill each
other when lions fight each other they
kill each other all the time
like that someone would have seen it by
now interesting all right so so you're
seeing my point is it just they they
they they want to get their feet wet
they're giving no credit for gorillas so
you're saying lion wins your money's
online no I'm saying lion would win in
the wild because they they can't kill
each other they can't end the fight it's
one of our most important criteria
um but Lions can almost always initiate
the action because they have much better
uh uh ability to see at night for
example Bears have very average night
vision Lions have superb night vision so
at night time they can always initiate
the fight lions are natural Ambush
Predators so it's always going to be
able to have the advantage of Ambush
um the great advantage that bears have
is endurance uh but bears are very
risk-averse and they're not used to
fighting
like the toughest toughest animals the
toughest animal they fight is a moose or
a caribou these are not not even close
to the animals that Lions have to go up
against on a regular basis so if
somebody wins it's going to be the lion
for you I still think that the size and
endurance of the bear if they were
locked in a cage together I would still
favor the beer under those circumstances
but in the wild I believe the beer will
back away cut it in the cage no time
limit you favor the bear what if it's
five rounds or five minutes Championship
then I would go with a lion because the
lion has a huge speed Advantage so it's
gonna it's gonna injure it tear it up
and uh and do immediate damage like I
put it this way if lion and bear fight
first 15 minutes I favor the line 100
but then as time goes by that size and
weight is gonna and endurance is going
to have an effect I I'll bring up
shortly somebody that's going to
probably disagree with you about some
things hopefully it's a grizzly bear and
it comes in and just eats me
oh that would be so epic
um making a hell of a podcast I wonder
who you would eat first who would look
scarier more delicious I'm not sure the
black and white could either piss him
off he would think you were a penguin
is that a good thing or not no good if
it was a polar bear maybe it's different
um
deeply about your uh about athletes you
coached about people in your life
so I have to ask this question
if one of those athletes let's say
Gordon Ryan
now I was the dictator of the world and
this would entertain me so I force you
and Gordon to do this uh to fight uh a
bear or a lion Gordon has to uh how
would you coach him to do it
uh to have any chance of winning
he goes in empty hand empty-handed you
can choose Stadium or
um cage
Gordon Ryan empty-handed versus a lion
you get to choose lion versus bear it's
up to you okay my advice would be very
simple yeah I would say Gordon you're
[ __ ]
you're going to die badly
choose the lion because it will strangle
you to death rather than pin you down
and Maul you to death
didn't we just talk about audacious
goals
this is not a question of audacious gold
this is a question of minimizing pain so
you coach your athletes to quit before
the battle has been fought 100 yeah
what's he gonna do you don't think
there's a technic first of all
intelligence so technically what you
gotta do a heel hook no no well first of
all maybe you kind of do a Double A's or
four [ __ ] legs okay what if Gordon
gets any starting position he wants oh
yeah that's going to be really useful
on a thousand pound beer yeah
[Music]
shaken off he'll get torn off with what
like the reaches back he's got four or
six inches oh you can't get I wonder
what is the reach whatever he touches
he's got if it's not a flexible bear
so you think there's no control what
about like a low like a uh some kind of
controlling position from yeah like you
said purple like from underneath nothing
this discussion is so insane I didn't
even know where to begin criticism I
don't think you're open-minded we could
we could turn this down forget about
Gordon fighting a a lion or a bear
that's that's completely impossible an
adult male chimp will destroy Gordon
it's not even a gorilla
is more than enough to kill any human on
the planet including Gordon Ryan so
Gordon Ryan fighting a chimp a good size
dead no a thousand times how many times
does he win he loses a thousand times
it's not even competitive it's not even
remotely compared do you think he will
disagree
no
do you think anyone will disagree anyone
yeah [ __ ]